La morte è un argomento Corale che ci
riguarda tutti e che dovrebbe per questo
riunire la comunità
Eppure nel corso della nostra vita
sono sicura che ognuno di noi è riuscito
a stabilire un rapporto
intimo
esclusivo con la morte e probabilmente
non l'ha condiviso con altri
questo è perché la morte costituisce un
tabù in occidente
ed è solo negli ultimi anni che anche in
Italia si è iniziato a parlare di Death
education
quando si parla di limiti Io penso in
automatico alla parola latina Limes che
è stata citata anche poco fa su questo
palco
e il Limes era una stradina che
delimitava dei campi confinanti quindi
non percepisco il limite come il confine
come la frontiera che include esclude
qualcosa bensì
lo vedo proprio come una strada una
strada da percorrere
Ed è proprio su questo sentiero che a
cavallo tra la vita e la morte che si
svolge il mio mestiere il lavoro della
tanat estetica
Che cos'è molti probabilmente lo
ignorano ma ecco è una pratica
consentita in Italia è una branca della
tanato prassi e la tanata estetica si
occupa di celare i primi effetti i primi
segni visibili della morte su un corpo
si occupa anche di effettuare piccole
ricostruzioni dove sia necessario
però mi rendo conto che questa
definizione
precisa Chiara concisa dice tutto e dice
niente
ed è per questo che io vi chiedo di
provare a sospendere per un attimo il
giudizio e
ascoltare e vedere insieme In che cosa
consiste realmente un trattamento di
tanatoestetica
la prima cosa da fare è osservare
osservare il corpo perché il corpo ci
parla e ci racconta tantissime cose non
solo le malattie gli interventi
trattamenti medici non solo la causa del
decesso ma ci dice molto di più di
quella persona e quando andiamo ad
osservare effettuare il trattamento da
anestetico dobbiamo tenere in conto
diverse diversi fattori
Innanzitutto dobbiamo tenere conto
dell'età
la corporatura l'alimentazione
considerare l'ambiente in cui viene
rinvenuto il corpo e la posizione
se per esempio sono stata vittima della
pantofolassassina e sono morta durante
il sonno davanti alla tv è probabile che
il mio corpo debba essere spostato
quindi Dobbiamo considerare tutte queste
cose all'inizio e poi in seconda battuta
iniziare veramente a occuparci del corpo
e la prima cosa da fare è pulirlo
lavarlo disinfettarlo
Questo è fondamentale perché quando
cessa l'attività Vitale Quindi quando
sopraggiunge la morte le difese
immunitarie decadono E noi siamo
abitualmente abitati da funghi virus
batteri
sono microbi e quando i muri delle
difese immunitarie non ci sono più
partono all'arrembaggio e per questo che
è fondamentale lavare la salma
soprattutto disinfettare il volto alle
mani che sono i punti che probabilmente
i dolenti andranno a toccare
poi dopo aver lavato si può pensare
anche a quella che in gergo viene detta
la messa in sicurezza per evitare le
fuoriuscite
spesso si pensa alle piaghe ed è vero ci
sono anche loro sono rare vanno trattate
in un dato modo ma in realtà quello che
tutti noi abbiamo sono proprio gli
orifizi e bisogna occuparsi di questo
dettaglio perché noi non vogliamo che ci
siano degli inconvenienti durante
l'ultimo saluto quello che fa una buona
tenuta
e andare a prevenire e andare a
immaginare come quel corpo reagirà con
il trascorrere delle ore in
quell'ambiente
e quindi se adesso state per esempio
pensando al pannolone Sì è una delle
possibilità sicuramente molto utile poco
ecologico ma molto gettonato in Italia
questo assolutamente sì ecco quindi come
vi dicevo la cosa importante è proprio
assicurarsi che non ci siano problemi
quando il corpo sarà poi all'interno
della cassa dell'imbottitura bianca
perché nulla deve andare a disturbare
l'ultimo saluto
dopo questo passaggio viene una parte un
po' più
particolare perché penso che nessuno se
lo immagini Ma i corpi vanno massaggiati
con una crema ad alta idratazione in
quanto tra i primi effetti e cadaverici
i primi effetti della morte su un corpo
c'è la disidratazione e quindi è
fondamentale effettuare un massaggio
delicato con una crema perché questo
massaggio permette di reidratare i
tessuti ma anche di stendere i
lineamenti del volto che potrebbero
essere contratti
il massaggio ci permette anche di
rimuovere eventuali macchie ipostatiche
queste macchie si formano a ridosso di
poche ore dal decesso e possono essere
rimosse appunto con il massaggio
Ma che cosa sono
Allora diciamo che tutti i corpi sono
sempre soggetti alla forza di gravità
vivi e morti pertanto quando la
circolazione sanguigna cessa i liquidi
normalmente
decadono si depositano si depositano sul
fondo e
fanno sì che si formino delle macchie
che possono avere un colore
bluastro violaceo rossastro dipende Ecco
il massaggio cerca di eliminarle
di sicuro quello che posso dirvi come
consiglio spassionato è di posizionare
sempre due bei cuscini dietro la nuca
dietro la testa perché in questo modo
aiutiamo la forza di gravità a far
fluire naturalmente i liquidi verso
un'altra parte evitando la formazione di
macchie sul volto orecchie e collo
e adesso Passiamo a un momento un po'
più intenso che è quello della
vestizione
per i non addetti ai lavori la
è più complicata perché prevede la messa
in movimento del corpo
sono movimenti piccoli studiati
calibrati Però
succede qualcosa nel nostro cervello c'è
un corto circuito perché noi siamo
abituati a relazionarci tra corpi vivi
Quindi io posso immaginare come reagirà
una persona a una mia carezza
ma non posso immaginare un corpo che non
reagisce è difficile per me capire che
quel corpo non reagisce più a nessuno
stimolo esterno ed è questa la parte più
difficile
Eppure anche la più importante perché ci
permette di realizzare che quel corpo
non ci sarà più
Ecco la vestizione è anche molto
commovente perché
ci permette di vestire il defunto
Seguendo le sue volontà quindi
possiamo assecondare le sue richieste o
quelle dei suoi familiari e in qualche
modo tutti noi siamo legati
abiti che ci contraddistinguono quindi
ci può essere la scelta di indossare
tailleur usato per il matrimonio oppure
la giacca preferita il foulard che si è
comprato nell'ultimo viaggio
Ecco tutte queste scelte sono ovviamente
importanti e vanno rispettate
Eppure
mi rendo conto che
per alcune persone questo trattamento
rischia di essere superfluo
D'altronde sta beneficiando di un
trattamento completo ma un trattamento
che non lo riporterà in vita e questo è
vero
però questo
pensiero Ecco questa sensazione
dell'inutilità della cura lo si ha solo
se si percepiscono le persone come isole
come corpi a sé stanti ma noi sappiamo
proprio perché ne abbiamo parlato prima
che siamo dei campi confinanti abbiamo
delle stradine che ci percorrono ci sono
legami relazioni solide e quindi quando
andiamo a effettuare un trattamento su
una salma
non è mai solo un corpo morto ma è
qualcosa di più è un padre una madre
un'amica un collega una sorella quindi
dobbiamo prestare diciamo attenzione
cura
e io mi interrogo anche sul fatto se sia
vero che la morte costituisca un limite
così invalicabile
se davvero interrompa tutte le
comunicazioni con chi amiamo
sono delle domande toste ve ne rendo
conto però
ve ne faccio una più semplice
avete mai sentito parlare dei telefoni
del vento
i telefoni del vento sono delle cabine
telefoniche
sconnesse dalla rete
quindi si entra nella cabina si alza la
cornetta
e si parla con il proprio defunto
il telefono del vento ci mette in
comunicazione con i nostri defunti e
semplicemente esplica in maniera
materiale visibile solida una nostra
necessità quella di continuare a
dialogare con i nostri legami più solidi
io sono sicura che ognuno di noi sarà
capitato di immaginare un dialogo quindi
Chissà cosa avrà detto nonno o
non avrebbe saputo l'ingrediente
mancante in questa ricetta quindi questo
dialogo
non si interrompe lo portiamo avanti noi
noi
fisicamente che siamo ancora qua noi che
ancora ci possiamo pensare parliamo
ancora con i nostri cari che non ci sono
più
Ed è proprio per chi resta
è proprio per Chi prosegue il discorso
che il trattamento di tanoestetica è
importante perché ci permette di
affrontare un evento drammatico come il
lutto senza intoppi senza il trauma
della morte
ed è per questo che la tanato estetica è
importante perché ci permette di
restituire dignità alla persona che non
c'è più
restituirle anche la possibilità di
scelta la possibilità di
autodeterminarsi fino all'ultimo e
garantirle la possibilità di farlo
questo è molto importante
e anche per quanto riguarda il trucco
dobbiamo
pensare a come quella persona avrebbe
voluto essere truccata Quindi
a che cosa teneva di più se avevo
un'attenzione particolare magari per le
unghie quindi fare la manicure oppure se
aveva utilizzava magari degli ombretti
sgargianti Ecco il tanto siete a tene
conto anche di questi particolari perché
un ombretto sgargiante su una palpebra
aperta e
con uno sguardo Vispo a una resa diversa
rispetto a una palpebra immobile e
chiusa quindi tenere conto di tutti
questi particolari permette a noi che
siamo ancora qui di poter effettuare un
saluto seno
un saluto che effettivamente trascenda
la morte
Ed è proprio in
contesti magari un po' più dolorosi
che
mi rendo conto dell'importanza del mio
lavoro quando per esempio dopo delle
lunghe malattie
le persone sono trasfigurate dal dolore
dalla sofferenza quindi a livello fisico
a livello psicologico e come se la
malattia ad un certo punto si prendesse
tutto si mangiasse la persona e non
restasse più niente ecco dopo delle
malattie così determinanti quando
sopraggiunge la morte e vado a fare
l'intervento Io
capisco di aver fatto un buon lavoro
Quando i familiari rientrando in stanza
esclamano Adesso sì che ti riconosco
Adesso sì che sei proprio tu